bonjour Jérôme ma chère merci beaucoup
de vous accompagner pendant cette
première demi-heure vous êtes élu de
l'Oise mon du groupe les républicains on
va évidemment parler de cette réforme
des retraites avec vous la journée de
mobilisation qui est annonce donc suivie
est-ce que vous craignez un blocage du
pays pour l'instant je vous
blocage du pays c'est tout à fait
logique que un certain nombre de
personnes manifestent c'est pas leur
projet c'est pas leur programme et je le
comprends
à de qui c'est projette dire de manière
obligatoire
vous aurez deux ans de plus à travailler
certains ont envie même de travailler
encore plus certains ne veulent jamais
s'arrêter certains ne s'arrêtent jamais
combien de médecins continuent à 70 ans
75 ans et c'est tant mieux d'ailleurs
parfois pour vu le nombre de médecins
vous voyez donc tout dépend des
professions il y a manifestation c'est
tout à fait logique on verra l'ampleur
de des Français qui sont pas contents à
priori de la réforme et ça va je veux
dire croissant bon depuis qu'on la
connaît il est assez logique que ce
texte qui apparaît plus pour l'instant
comme une réforme comptable c'est-à-dire
équilibrée les régimes de retraite et
notamment les régimes le régime général
c'est-à-dire celui des salariés
et le paradoxe c'est que ce sont plutôt
les fonctionnaires qui vont aller
manifester
vous voyez les professeurs des écoles
qui sont en grève très largement les
cheminots ce sont plutôt ceux sous
statut public qui vont manifester alors
que le premier sujet concerne
l'équilibre du régime des salariés il y
a des petites choses qu'il faut dire
comme ça ils ont le sentiment que ça
être dans leur majorité que cette
réforme est injuste c'est ça pour vous
elle est comptable elle est comptable
d'abord et c'est ça que avec Xavier
Bertrand et le parti les républicains et
au Sénat nous allons faire attention à
ce qu'il y a aussi un équilibre de
justice évidemment pour les petites
retraites pour les carrières longues
pour la pénibilité et ce sujet là il est
un peu pas assez bien traité on verra
dans la discussion parlementaire oui il
y a un côté comme ça on ne dit pas tout
à fait ses intentions on fait un peu
trop dehors en même temps sur la partie
juste sociale si vous voulez l'équilibre
social il y a l'équipe comptable qui est
celui que le Sénat des forts depuis
plusieurs années depuis 4 ans exactement
et que nous avons voté donc là on
n'avons pas de problème et puis il y a
l'équilibre social et celui-là il est
pas assez clair de la part du
gouvernement donc on crée de
l'inquiétude plutôt que on crée des
envies et des aspirations mais on vous
sentez réservés finalement sur cette
réforme de retraite est-ce qu'en l'état
de ce qu'on en connaît sera présenté
l'Indien conseil de ministre mais est-ce
quand l'état de ce qu'on en connaît vous
avez envie de la voter en l'état non
mais l'état moi je veux aussi de
l'équilibre social et de pour le moment
c'est non mais pour l'instant oui parce
que il y a un équilibre comptable
première partie je vote oui
il y a une deuxième partie et c'est là
où tout se joue tout se joue là-dessus
et ça c'est maltraité par le
gouvernement parce que pour faire cette
réforme là tel que présenter aujourd'hui
il suffisait de le faire dans le projet
de loi de finance de la sécurité sociale
vu que c'est ça qui vont faire
finalement cet automne ils l'ont
envisagé l'épuisement et puis on va
négocier puis en fait on négocie jamais
avec le gouvernement en vérité il dit
qu'il concerte mais en fait il vous
présente son projet vous parlez et puis
de façon c'est son projet donc on verra
si au Parlement c'est la même chose
comme non plus complètement la majorité
ni à l'Assemblée ni au Sénat et bien le
texte va être amené à évoluer
dans votre dans votre cas pour le moment
bien sûr qu'au moment
on votera la nôtre et pas forcément la
le alors qu'est-ce que dans le fond
qu'est-ce qui différencie qu'est-ce qui
vous manque qu'est-ce que vous demandez
à Elisabeth band de mettre dans ce texte
pour pouvoir le voter par exemple pour
les petites retraites il y a un sujet
sur est-ce que ce sont ceux qui vont
partir à la retraite avec une carrière
complète au SMIC qui seront à 1200 euros
ou plus exactement à 85% du SMIC net
parce que le SMIC évolue donc 1200 euros
a évoluera aussi où est-ce que c'est le
stock et aujourd'hui nous dit ah non le
stock c'est pas sûr c'est pas dans le
texte ah bah oui mais si quand même
alors
que d'habitude
pour vous c'est pas à qui tout ça n'est
pas dans le thème oui c'est pas dans le
texte donc moi je vote un texte je vote
pas des déclarations sinon en fout avec
tout ce qui a déclaré le président
Macron je sais pas où on en serait non
mais c'est vraiment important et tout ce
que déclare le gouvernement une fois
c'est Monsieur du stop qui dit quelque
chose une fois c'est Madame
une fois c'est le président Macron et on
a trois versions donc moi je n'attends
pas des paroles j'attends un texte de
loi et quand le texte de loi
correspondra aux actes voilà il y a des
choses à faire sur la pénibilité il y a
des et puis il y a quand même deux
choses qui manquent c'est un texte des
d'équilibre il y a l'emploi des seniors
parce que si vous mettez 64 ans vous
laissez 10 ans les gens au chômage ça
n'a pas de sens alors là il y a un index
pour vous c'est pas suffisant il faut
des mesures contraignantes pour les
entreprises
c'est une usine à gaz l'index
aller voilà qu'est-ce qu'il faut des
mesures contraignantes il faut aller
plus loin pour effectivement que les
entreprises notamment les plus grandes
conservent les seniors et alors c'est
d'ailleurs assez parlé comme ça
aujourd'hui il y a plus de on vire plus
les seigneurs parce que on cherche de la
main d'oeuvre de partout donc il faut
aussi qu'on change le logiciel on a
raisonné sur 40 ans de chômage élevé et
dorénavant on cherche partout des gens
qui veulent travailler donc c'est là où
il faut voir si les gens veulent
travailler peuvent travailler
l'autre sujet et enfin il y a notre
sujet
est-ce qu'on contraint les entreprises
le patronat ne veut pas de contraintes
est-ce que vous dites le patronat doit
être contraint à garder les seniors il
ne peut pas être contraint si long avant
mais il y a un sujet sur le niveau
salarial aussi des seniors et accepter
que dans la vie on ne progresse pas
toujours du niveau salarial et qui on
peut avoir une productivité moindre et
le sujet qui est vraiment important
c'est de pouvoir partir parfois à la
retraite de manière progressive plus
facilement pour être physiquement un peu
mieux notamment quand vous avez des
métiers un peu pénibles c'est cet
équivaut là vous savez il faut quand
même pas rigoler quand un professeur se
retrouve face à des gamins d'aujourd'hui
par rapport au gamin qu'il a connu il y
a 40 ans
c'est pas toujours la même chose c'est
parfois plus fatiguant et on peut
regarder sur des retraites progressives
je crois qu'on va pas assez loin sur la
retraite progressive voilà il y a des
choses à penser un peu plus avant
sur la procédure parlementaire vous en
avez un petit peu parlé le gouvernement
utilise une procédure parlementaire qui
limite le nombre de jours de débats
est-ce que pour vous c'est une bonne
chose ou est-ce qu'il aurait dû employer
notre procédure c'est à dire que comme
le la dupesse a annoncé à un moment
170000 allemands
non plus donc moi je suis toujours déçu
que l'on n'est pas un débat
parlementaire raisonné
et c'est ce que nous faisons au Sénat au
Sénat on a toujours un débat raisonné
sur sur ce plateau qui préside le groupe
socialiste au Sénat et qui dit qu'il
s'opposerait évidemment à cette réforme
par tous les moyens mais qui
n'excluaient pas lui aussi de déposer un
grand nombre d'amendements qu'est-ce que
vous en pensez avoir il peut y avoir un
grand nombre d'abondements c'est un
texte très technique il y a beaucoup de
cas donc il peut y avoir beaucoup de
discussions et il faut qu'il y ait la
discussion et le débat parce que il n'a
pas eu lieu dans l'opinion publique ça
fait plusieurs mois que le gouvernement
dit
le consulte voilà mais en vérité ne sort
rien donc il faut qu'on ait des
positions publiques sur tous ces débats
alors ça va être ça commence maintenant
parce qu'il a dit clairement pendant la
campagne
donc oui c'est ça le problème c'est que
au pire il lui dit le faire dans la
foulée il ne l'a pas fait il aurait pu
le faire cet automne pour cette réforme
là il ne l'a pas fait donc tout ça c'est
soyez il y a un côté un peu brouillon
c'est le problème de de même Macron qui
n'a pas de cap et qui fait les choses
d'ailleurs Édouard Philippe lui a
reproché dans le point de jeudi
excusez-moi de citer un journal
Philippe il dit mais est-ce que c'était
prioritaire là maintenant
oui enfin c'était prioritaire il y a
trois ans ils ont fini par rater le truc
en faisant une très fort
incompréhensible et qui menaçait tout et
là on a une réforme qui vient maintenant
dans un procédure qui est faite pour
éviter et permettre au gouvernement de
faire un 49-3 la vérité c'est ça temps
limité 49-3 possible et comme ça on
regarde continuer à regarder les
cartouches de 49-3 parce que le
gouvernement en vérité est empêché c'est
juste le problème de ligne claire on va
passer à l'actualité du Sénat mais Sénat
qui a donc voté un texte qui a donc fini
pardon terminé d'examiner un texte sur
le nucléaire le vote ça sera un petit
peu plus tard on en parle avec notre
journaliste parlementaire
[Musique]
publication dont je viens de parler le
gouvernement voulait la limiter à 15 ans
le Sénat a préféré 20 ans en ce qui
concerne les autres modifications on va
écouter Daniel Gremillet le rapporteur
LR du texte il était hier sur ce plateau
moi j'ai souhaité deux choses en tant
que rapporteur simplifié sécurisé tenir
compte et aujourd'hui de l'évolution
climatique
par exemple lorsqu'on a une centrale en
bord de mer j'ai renforcé la sécurité
tenant compte de l'érosion tenant compte
de l'élévation du niveau de la mer des
vagues sur merci etc ce sont des sujets
et puis un autre point que j'ai renforcé
aussi dans le texte c'est la cyber
résilience on voit bien que les risques
d'aujourd'hui ne sont pas plus les
risques d'hier première question
monsieur bachel est-ce que c'est
suffisant pour rassurer le secteur du
nucléaire et permettre les embauches
notamment
qu'il y ait des gens formés qui ont
envie d'aller dans ce secteur là et
comme on a découragé depuis 20 ans à peu
près 15 ans exactement 15 ans ce Jacques
Chirac a pas eu de problème je peux le
dire j'étais au cabinet de mise à la
recherche sous Jacques Chirac et donc je
peux vous dire qu'on a lancé le père de
Flamanville qu'on espérait qu'il soit
fini pour 2010 vous voyez que on a un
peu de retard et pour le même coup non
donc on ne sait plus faire on ne sait
plus faire de soudure tout bêtement donc
par exemple donc ça a quand même un peu
embêtant on fait venir des soudeurs
américains pour donc on a un problème de
formation et d'habitude de travail c'est
un texte correct
juste que c'est vous ne l'avez pas
repris ni Daniel grimmiel là-dedans qui
est un grand spécialiste de l'énergie
c'est que il faut d'abord dire quel est
le mix énergétique de la France et c'est
simple
c'est la deuxième partie de cette
chronique justement
avant-hier pardon vous avez aussi
exprimer l'objectif de réduction de 50%
du nucléaire dans le mix énergétique
alors pour la petite histoire le
gouvernement espéré en fait faire
adopter ce texte technique sans faire de
politique évidemment un voeux pieux
temps le sujet et sensible alors vous
êtes agacé hier vous avez déjà commencé
à le rappeler le gouvernement voulait
parler en fait de la manière de
construire ses EPR avant même de voter
la feuille de route qui fera l'objet
d'un nouveau texte ce sera en juin
prochain en clair le gouvernement met la
charrue avant les boeufs c'est ce que
vous lui avez rappelé vous avez donc
glissé un peu de politique dans ce texte
en rappelant comme comme je l'ai dit
l'objectif vous avez supprimé l'objectif
de réduction de 50% de nucléaires dans
le mix d'ici 2035 voici la réponse de la
ministre à cette suppression
mathématiquement et ça c'est les
scénarios RTE même en construisant 14
réacteurs nucléaires à horizon 2050 je
me place horizon 2050 dans le meilleur
des scénarios ça a été rappelé et c'est
les mathématiques c'est-à-dire qu'à un
moment on peut se faire plaisir
politiquement mais il y a quand même la
physique qui nous rattrape le maximum de
la part du nucléaire c'est 50%. je le
rappelle dans ces scénarios de RTE de la
part du renouvelable dans les 15 ans qui
viennent va augmenter dans notre mix
énergétique en tout cas c'est ce que je
ne souhaite si nous voulons vraiment
bâtir une indépendance énergétique
qu'est-ce que vous lui répondez ah bah
c'est triste c'est triste effectivement
de faire n'importe quoi sur l'énergie il
fallait d'abord revoir le mix
énergétique dans une loi de
programmation de l'énergie puis faire le
texte sur les énergies renouvelables et
le l'énergie nucléaire on fait tout dans
le désordre
savez-vous qu'on doit encore fermer 12
réacteurs aujourd'hui dans les textes et
donc c'est ça que nous avons abrogé nous
manquons des électricité nous l'avons vu
l'Europe et inquiète en pénurie et nous
nous continuons à fermer 12 réacteurs
nucléaires nous connaît continuons à
dire que on a bien fait de fermer
festenheim pour cet hiver c'est absurde
absurde et ils sont pris dans leur
contradiction permanente c'est bien ça
le problème de dure en même temps c'est
que c'est des sujets qu'ils auraient dû
traiter dans la quinquennat d'avant
qu'ils n'ont pas fait et donc ils vont
pas aller jusqu'à se renier c'est
n'importe quoi le problème si vous
voulez moi je le dis très clairement ce
gouvernement est le cap enfin le leur
chef Emmanuel Macron parce qu'il
obéissent qu'à la volonté d'Emmanuel
Macron qui on sait pas ce qu'il pense le
matin et le soir et bien n'a aucun sens
il y a aucun sens à tout ça on fait
exactement l'inverse de ce qu'on a fait
5 ans auparavant tout ce texte sur NRJ
qui était pensé par la gauche par la
gauche
n'aide pas été du tout remis en cause
tout premier quinquennat Macron et c'est
pour ça nous retrouvons dans cette
situation cette catastrophique quelle
doit être pour vous la part de quelle
doit être la part du nucléaire parce que
au moins 50%, qu'est-ce concrètement
elle doit être de combien aujourd'hui
entre 50 et 60 voilà tout simplement
donc voilà le développement des 2005
c'est toujours 2050
c'est absolument catastrophique de dire
qu'on doit encore fermer 12 réacteurs
nucléaires mais ça on le dit pas si
c'est pas dans le texte donc c'est ça le
problème c'est que c'est un décret donc
on a arbre Rogé l'article de loi qui
oblige à changer le décret voilà nous on
sait on sait faire aussi un peu de
politique et on sait faire un peu la loi
mais vous voyez c'est ce truc non non
toutes ces techniques le nucléaires non
mais non mais non c'est la dépendance de
la France c'est la souveraineté on en
parle matin midi et soir et on fait
l'inverse ce matin midi et soir c'est
assez insupportable de la part du
président de la République et de son
gouvernement alors la ministre l'a
rappelé il va falloir du renouvelable
c'est un sujet dans votre territoire
justement comment on l'aborde alors on
aborde de manière positive c'est que les
énergies renouvelables ces trois choses
principalement par chez moi
l'éolien très développé trop développé
qui commence à fatiguer un certain
nombre de d'habitants le solaire et ça
commence parce que on avait beaucoup
freiné sur le soleil et là on va une
grande par exemple on va avoir une
grande ferme photovoltaïque sur
l'ancienne base aérienne de Creil sur
les pistes on va avoir une des plus
grandes fermes photovoltaïques le projet
est en train d'avancer voyons on a
beaucoup de méthaniseurs et même les
méthaniseurs à partir de
de coproduit agricoles et bien comment
ça a créé quelques soucis parce que vous
avez évidemment des tracteurs pour
emmener ces produits etc donc tout n'est
pas aussi simple mais tous ces projets
là avancent on n'a pas enfin c'est bien
qu'une loi d'accélération mais il faut
aussi bien passer et ça c'est maintenant
la ligne rouge je crois fixée par le
Sénat la Commission mixparitaire est
bientôt pour l'éolien dans l'Oise et
puis je peux vous assurer le groupe les
répliquer pour vous dire pas le
contraire je veux qu'il y ait un droit
pour les mères de dire oui ou non oui ou
non mais pas les mers conseils
municipaux pour que ce soit bien
démocratique ça c'est dans la loi
énergie renouvelable la commission
disparitaire c'est la semaine prochaine
alors je le rappelle vous avez fixé un
câble vous avez pris un peu d'avance
finalement sur le texte de programmation
énergétique qui doit normalement arriver
cet été Greenpeace fustige cette
décision ils avancent que vous
court-circuiter l'agenda à législatif et
le débat sur le nucléaire qu'est ce que
vous répondez non mais les choses dans
le bon sens Greenpeace je crois pas
qu'ils aient fait jusqu'à présent la
bonne politique énergétique pour la
France on vient de le voir et donc
c'était plutôt des gens qui soustaient
d'autres énergies
et bien sûr c'est le moment le moment
c'est quand vous faites d'abord une loi
de programmation puis après vous
déclinez les affaires là on fait on
déclic et puis enfin ça doit faire une
loi de programmation c'est l'inverse on
fait tout en sens
mauvais sens parce que tout part
d'Emmanuel Macron du haut vers le bas il
faut passer par le bas vers les
territoires les besoins et après on fait
on fait remonter les choses c'est on
fait vraiment c'est une méthode qui est
catastrophique cette méthode
catastrophique c'est la même que pour
les retraites la méthode est
catastrophique chez Emmanuel Macron et
c'est pour ça qu'il ne tient pas de
résultats merci Audrey tout à l'heure on
va continuer à parler nucléaire
on va voir l'actualité dans votre
département de l'Oise on retrouve
Vincent Gérard bonjour Vincent merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous directeurs de
la publication de wazebdo et vous
souhaitez revenir sur le prochain
scrutin sénatorial ce sera au mois de
septembre et dans l'Oise ce sont trois
nuances de LR si on peut dire
c'est exactement ça on s'occupe de ce
qui va se passer dans huit mois lors des
sénatoriales mais aujourd'hui on va
s'occuper beaucoup des grèves qui vont
avoir lieu dans le département des
manifestations il y a trois
manifestations prévues dans le
département comme moi c'est à peu près
1% du département de la France il
suffira de multiplier par par 100 le
résultat donc s'il y a 10000 grévistes
et 10000 manifestants il y aura
peut-être un million dans l'ensemble de
la force donc on va suivre ça avec
beaucoup d'intérêts mais on suit aussi
naturellement ce qui va se passer dans
les sénates pour les sénatoriales qui
vont arriver dans 8 mois et
naturellement du côté de LR on se pose
des questions puisque il y a trois
nuances de LR et pas de femmes il y a
Jérôme Bacher le LR présent ici et qui a
LR pur jus il y a Édouard courscial LR
mis sous tutelle il y a un petit peu en
délicatesse avec le parti et puis il y a
Olivier Pacaud LR apparentée LR et ce
qu'ils vont faire trois listes c'est ce
qu'ils vont faire donc c'est la question
et s'ils vont faire trois listes
d'hommes pour éviter d'avoir des femmes
d'autant plus que du côté du Parti
socialiste apparemment Laurence
Rossignol ne serait plus là la sénatrice
et ce serait un homme donc il y aurait
la loi serait représentée au Parlement
par cat sénateurs hommes et cette
députée homme
c'est une bonne question Vincent Gerard
alors après il faut pas avancer que nous
avons une préfète de loisune présidente
de département de l'Oise la présidente
de l'agglomération de Beauvais qui est
une femme de Méru les plus grosses
communes de Chantilly 200 lisses de
Noyon de crépi en Valois bon la forme de
la gendarmerie aussi la patrouille de la
colonel la gendarmerie merci et ainsi de
suite pour l'ARS voilà bon bref
c'est vrai que il y aura un sujet quand
même de parité chez les parlementaires
si jamais c'était le scénario que vous
décrivez
bon ben c'est comme ça on est ensemble
de sortant je ne crois pas que on est
forcément tous démérités et donc voilà
on est on se représente aussi sur un
bilan et puis ce sont les acteurs de de
choisir il peut y avoir d'autres listes
et une liste qui sera peut-être conduite
je ne sais pas par la République en
marche
qui est très présente dans le
département ça c'était
mensonge clair et net qui peut être
dirigé par une femme et qui peut être
élue donc on verra bien moi je ne fais
pas de pronostic il est à peu près
certain aujourd'hui que les trois
sénateurs qui sont dans le gueux qui
siège au groupe LR repartiront sur trois
listes différentes ça fait moi je le dis
hein
que je conduirai ça fait pas beaucoup
trois nuances de LR
correspond plutôt à des nuances de
droite parce que Olivier Pacaud n'est
pas élèves il ne l'était pas la fois
dernière non plus vous voyez donc c'est
aussi il y a beaucoup de mères et vous
savez beaucoup de d'élus qui ne sont
plus encartés voilà moi je le suis je le
maintiens parfois c'est pas toujours les
résultats que je veux et je suis pas sûr
que ce soit la grande forme de mon parti
politique c'est pas le RPR que j'ai
connu dans l'Oise mais voilà non non
repartira à chacun et il y aura beaucoup
de femmes de qualité d'ailleurs je peux
le dire elle est très simplement il y a
quand même dorénavant et c'est quand
j'ai cité tout Stéphane président de
l'intercommunalité aussi rurale
il y a énormément de femmes de qualité
de politique de qualité dans l'Oise je
tiens à le dire
on est parti pour avoir encore des
hommes et que des hommes qui ne
représentent au Parlement
parce que vous étiez un péronique sur la
présence de la République en marche de
renaissance dans votre département il y
a un parti quand même qui a fait des
bons scores aux dernières élections
c'est le rassemblement national est-ce
que ils seront en mesure pour vous
d'avoir un sénateur ils ont un
Ulysse comme à chaque fois après donc
c'est extrêmement limité le nombre de
grands électeurs de grands secteurs
pardon
n'est pas suffisant il le savent donc
voilà et mais ils feront leur liste
rassurez-vous moi je sais pas si ça vous
réduite
de gauche en revanche très intéressant
parce que
eux ont la fois dernière était séparés
est-ce que cette fois-ci ils seront unis
au sein de la nupesse est-ce qu'il y
aura une France insoumise ou une église
d'extrême gauche ça ça peut être
intéressant parce que les résultats
peuvent être
c'est à quelques voix près vous savez
sur ce tatoriales on va regarder la
une trop de Marouane de mise en examen
c'est à la Une de votre journal merci
beaucoup Vincent Gérard d'avoir été avec
nous puisqu'on parlait des républicains
un mot sur votre partie puisqu'on
connaît enfin l'équipe de direction
erikiotti la dévoile ce matin dans Le
Figaro il sera entouré de deux vices
présidents Aurélien Pradier qui était
donc candidat et qui a perdu et
François-Xavier Bellamy très proche de
Bruno Retailleau c'est un bon équilibre
effectivement des trois forces qui se
sont présentées il y a aussi un souhait
je trouve de jeunesse et de
renouvellement vous voyez il y a Pradier
François-Xavier Bennani c'est pas tout à
fait des anciens ministres de Jacques
Chirac quoi donc c'est plutôt pas mal en
terme de renouvellement aussi d'image
pourquoi pas il y a une hygène Var parce
que je voudrais pas que on reproche qui
est secrétaire général du parti donc
voilà il y a un équilibre qui est en
train de se créer juste on l'entend là
sur la réforme des retraites il est pas
franchement dans la ligne du parti il
dit que pour le moment il votre appel à
la réforme on peut être vice-président
d'un parti dont on ne suis pas la ligne
n'hésitez pas dit qu'ils avaient pas
suivi il dit pour l'instant et dans
l'état c'est ce que je viens de vous
dire moi je pense que je voterai le
texte du Sénat je vous le dis parce que
je vois bien ce que ce qui est prévu par
mon ami René Paul Savary
donc le texte du Sénat il y a pas de
doute je le voterai des gouvernement
voilà donc il va voilà il faut qu'on
verger il faut voilà il y a des
équilibres à trouver un dernier mot
puisque ce matin dans Le Figaro dit
redis que les républicains sont imparti
d'opposition pas les supplétifs
d'Emmanuel Macron pas d'alliance mais
comment vous opposez à un gouvernement
qui présente des mesures des textes que
vous proposez depuis des années que vous
défendez depuis des années il propose
des mesures techniques oui sur le
nucléaire et donc nous on fait de la
politique et voilà nous on ne fait pas
exactement la même chose quand je vous
ai dit que je ne voterai pas le texte de
Madame born dans l'état c'est que j'ai
bien conscience que ce texte n'est pas
totalement équilibré il est équilibré
comptablement il n'est pas équilibré
socialement merci Jérôme Bacher on aura
l'occasion de parler de la réforme des
retraites avec pour l'examen du texte ça
a priori en mars au Sénat merci d'avoir
été notre invité ce matin dans 20
minutes dans le club des territoires on
reparle réforme des retraites comment la
mobilisation se prépare en région on ira
du côté Toulouse et de Marseille et puis
on parlera du nucléaire la filière
est-elle prête à construire de nouveaux
réacteurs sur ces deux sujets débats
entre le maire socialiste de Rouen
Nicolas Mayer Rossignol et le sénateur
Gérard Longuet et tout de suite on
accueille notre prochaine invité
Philippe Martinez nous rejoint